series finales can be tough to pull off
or even the best TV shows they have to
wrap all the show's plot lines and
character arcs in a way that is
satisfactory and sensical sometimes that
means the show will close on a question
mark to allow fans their own
interpretations or perhaps even room for
a spinoff and while that might work with
some programs and open-ended finale can
often seem so unfinished that bands are
less clamoring for answers years after
the fact to help resolve some of the
most frustrating show endings here's a
look at what showrunners really meant
for fans to take away from these
confusing conclusions lost for a show
that was already redefining weird lost
last episode really went off the rails
the fifth season ended with jack and the
crew setting off a hydrogen bomb on the
island while visiting the 1970s so the
sixth and final season picked up with
two separate timelines one where the
survivors are still stuck on the island
of the present and another where the
plane seemingly never crashed this
alternate timeline soon revealed itself
to be much different than the original
and many of the characters were living
completely different lives
the final episode revealed that this
timeline was actually the afterlife
Carlton Cuse and Damon Lindelof later
explained that the afterlife plotline
was supposed to demonstrate how the
events on the island weren't purgatory
as many suspected unfortunately the
message was so well lost in the chaos of
the sideways world exploration that even
they couldn't really explain all the
finite details the Sopranos the fade to
black finish for The Sopranos was so
unexpected that many viewers thought
their cable feed had been interrupted
when it happened fans of the show had
spent months and months speculating
about what incredible drama would befall
Tony Soprano and his family to close out
such an eventful show but none of that
happened instead Tony his wife Carmela
and their kids meta for dinner after an
excruciating lead run out parallel
parking job I met up with journey's
don't stop believin blaring out over all
the inaction
Tony noticed a suspicious man lurking
around the diner and
[Music]
according to series creator David Chase
be ending applied that Tony was always
going to be paranoid as a result of his
mafioso history and that endings were
guys like Tony tend to happen just that
quickly and unexpectedly thanks to some
frame-by-frame analysis after the fact
it's pretty clear that the guy Tony was
eyeing who went to the bathroom nearby
his table probably ended his life right
then and there but the fact that chase
chose not to actually show his death was
irritating considering the show wasn't
shy about showcasing some serious
brutality before Parks and Recreation
the final season of Parks and Recreation
jumped forward in time a few years to
2017 in which Leslie Knope has become a
regional director of the National Park
Service but if all that time trippin
wasn't enough the series finale skipped
even further ahead to detail the next
few years in the lives of all the main
characters particularly Leslie and her
husband fellow Pawnee government worker
Ben Wyatt
both were approached to run for governor
of Indiana would Leslie said to have
served two terms in the post while Ben
went on to serve in Congress Joe Biden
knows his way around the seafood risotto
then much farther along in the future
they attend the funeral of Jerry gergich
with a Secret Service detail of dough
that means either Leslie or Ben is
President of the United States but who
is it show creator Mike sure inspired by
the ambiguity of the finale of The
Sopranos said he felt there was room for
one big question mark sure told variety
that he wanted people to be able to fill
in their own blanks and make up their
own minds considering the fact that
Leslie Knope always had oval office
ambitions it was probably her but the
fact that we didn't get to find out for
sure meant fans had to order extra
waffles to cope 30 rock NBC's 30 rock
seemed to have a relatively
straightforward finale going full meta
by having their faux show TGS wrap up in
conjunction with the real shows in but
there was one element of the Big Finish
that was extremely odd in the very last
scene of the show which takes place
several generations in the future Liz
Lemon's granddaughter is all grown up
and is pitching a show about her grand
other to the new head of the network who
just so happens to be and apparently
immortal Kenneth throughout the show
Kenneth was an NBC page who is painted
as something of a simpleton but in
retrospect the show might have been
building to the reveal that Kenneth was
a timeless creature all along after all
how many references did can it make to
old actors and songs that were so
obscure even those in the entertainment
business around him couldn't keep up I
was pretty addicted to coke back in my
Wall Street days Mad Men after nearly a
decade of failed marriages salacious
Affairs a bunch of booze and a deep dive
into his abandoned identity Donald
Draper escaped his life as a snazzy
Madison Avenue executive and sought
solace in a hippie commune his journey
to rock bottom was the very fabric of
Mad Men 7 seasons so when he showed up
at a California hideaway desperately
weeping over his mistakes and emotional
disconnection
it seemed like done might finally change
his ways but that final shot of him
peacefully meditating in Mass was not
the end-all be-all for the creative
geniuses days in the Sun the series
ended with the credits cut away to the
famous 1971 coca-cola commercial of a
cross-cultural singing group chanting
about wanting to buy the world a coke
and indicated that Don's takeaway from
so much self-discovery was really just
another awesome ad idea Mad Men creator
Matthew Weiner later agreed that Don
indeed remained an adman to the end as
the commercial suggested saying why not
in this show with the greatest
commercial ever made I am NOT into
ambiguity for ambiguities sake but it
was nice to have your cake and eat it
too in terms of what is advertising who
is Don and what is that thing as a
result viewers were left thirsty for
more so the choice of a soda ad was
certainly inspired thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
the school stuff we know you love to
you